ni écrire compter obéir lire écrire
compter obéir ne pas bouger ne pas
copier l'école le dessin de l'école
n'est-il pas plus vaste plus signifiants
alors il y a deux ans je me trouve à
ahmedabad ahmedabad c'est une ville au
nord ouest de l'inde une ville de 6
millions d'habitants fief de gandhi et
là je me trouve face à un jeune
adolescent il a 14 ans il s'appelle josh
hill est probablement très atypique
il a beaucoup de multi potentiel aussi
et josh hill a en face de moi puis il
revêt un bandeau noir un grand bandeau
noir qu'il empêche absolument devoir
puis josh et moi nous nous trouvons dans
une bibliothèque
je me retourne je me saisis d'un livre
au hasard
et puis je lui confie le livre et puis
là il va le porter à son visage sans
rien voir et puis va être capable de me
de sentir les couleurs il me dit voilà
il ya du bleu il ya du jaune et du rouge
du noir et du blanc
je reprends le livre je louche toujours
au hasard je veux dire confie et puis là
il va passer sa main devant le livre et
puis il va être capable de lire ce
entrevue rien voir le premier mot puis
une phrase culte premier paragraphe
alors là je suis fasciné par ce que je
constate
et je me pose un certain nombre de
questions comment est ce qu'il fait est
ce que la science a une explication à ça
est ce que d'autres enfants sont
capables de la même prouesse
et puis surtout à quoi ça peut bien
servir et alors ce qui est étonnant
c'est que de cet état de sidération de
fascination que je vis en fait petit à
petit je vais passer un état
d'émerveillement
mais un état d'émerveillement pour tout
autre chose
pourquoi bien parce qu'en fait je me
trouve avec josh dans une école cette
école là s'appelle la mahatma gandhi
international school est en fait elle
est le fruit d'un couple que vous voyez
il ya on joue et pascal en dessous et
indiennes passe car les français et tous
deux il ya 20 ans ont décidé de créer
une école une école différente
pourquoi parce qu'ils en avaient ils
s'ennuient et beaucoup à l'école ils ont
vécu une scolarité ou se sont beaucoup
en juillet et donc ils sont dit on veut
pas ça pour nos enfants
et on voudrait créer autre chose donc au
coeur de leurs de leurs idées d'école il
y à un concept 5 qui est tout et
ressources
les enfants sont une ressource l'espace
est une ressource
les corses ont des ressources des objets
tout et ressources donc une sorte de
frugalité quelque part et puis en fait
cette cette simple idée toutes les
ressources va les amener à développer de
l'inclusion et de la diversité
donc tous les enfants que nous qu'ils
viennent quels qu'ils soient sont les
bienvenus dans cette école notamment 20%
de l'effectif est composé des enfants de
basses castes
c'est un minimum il ya des enfants de
toutes confessions vous voyez
probablement vous avez entendu parler
d'eux
et des émeutes enfin pas des émeutes des
des difficultés avec l'inde en ce moment
même eh bien il ya 20 ans il ya eu les
mêmes difficultés à cause de cette école
et l'armée il vient l'armée a dû
intervenir pour que les enfants puissent
accéder à l'école qui était dans une
ouverture et une diversité hors du
commun puisque encore une fois tout est
et où toutes les enfants étaient bien
venus de toutes confessions les enfants
aussi bien handicapé que autistes ou ou
surdoué multi potentiels étaient les
bienvenus alors cette diversité elle se
coupe aussi d'une ouverture au
territoire d'une ouverture à la nature
et puis surtout le point importe très
important c'est une ouverture aux
dimensions intérieures
donc les enfants sont incités en
permanence à exprimer leurs émotions à
travailler leur empathie à mieux
connaître qu'ils sont à l'intérieur à
faire parfois de la méditation d'autres
activités y compris bien évidemment le
côté ludique des choses alors je me
retrouve dans le petit bureau de pascal
et d'anjou et puis l'un pour illustrer
sa demande je me raconte une une
histoire elle me dit voilà les enfants
ils travaillent en multidisciplinarité
ils choisissent souvent les projets et
lors d'un de ces projets qui était
d'organiser une fête pour l'école dans
lequel tous les acteurs sont invités
bien évidemment les parents les
entreprises les collectivités
territoriales tout le monde est le
bienvenu et bien une partie des enfants
étaient chargés d'aller acheter des
aliments d'autres cuisines à des gâteaux
d'autres encore les vendaient et puis
tout le surplus me dit elle avec
beaucoup d'émotion dans la voix
tout le surplus est distribué dans la
rue à des pauvres et des indigents et un
jour elle voit un homme entouré
d'enfants qui s'effondre dans la rue en
larmes et il s'effondre dans la rue
pourquoi parce que c'est pas c'est pas
parce qu'on lui avait donné des gâteaux
c'est parce que il avait vu dans le
regard d'enfant des enfants qui
pouvaient être considérés une nouvelle
fois comme un être humain ce qu'il avait
oublié depuis
beaucoup de temps alors en sortant de
cette école on y reste en une semaine
je pars avec deux deux enseignements
essentiels
le premier c'est que les enfants dans ce
type d'école garde intact leur curiosité
développe une autonomie qui va leur
permettre de choisir ce qu'ils veulent
et qui va leur permettre aussi d'aller
explorer l'intérieur d'eux-mêmes ce pour
quoi ils sont faits quels sont leurs
potentiels certains iront à sciences po
d'autres à harvard dont décideront de
rester en inde pour venir artisans ou
initiateurs c'est le terme qu'on emploie
pour le mot professeur la base ce sont
des initiateurs et puis deux
signalements saignements et bien en fait
cette école commence à faire école dans
toute l'inde dans toute l'inde est
aujourd'hui pascal et en duo était
sollicité par l'équivalent du ministère
de l'éducation nationale pour former 20
mille écoles soit un million de
professeurs et 20 millions d'enfants
tout ça avec des vidéos du e-learning
qui est fait d'ailleurs dans d'autres
écoles alors je reviens en france avec
avec une envie nice et celle de partager
et puis surtout de regarder s'il ya
d'autres écoles de ce type qui existe
alors bonne nouvelle il y en a d'autres
j'en trouve une au canada s'appelle
l'école des bouts je crois et cette
école dans cette école les enfants
passent trois jours par semaine quel que
soit le temps en pleine forêt il y
développe une relation avec une intimité
avec la faune et la flore
exceptionnelles mais en fait il ya pas
besoin d'aller en inde ou au canada
on en trouve aussi en france pas très
loin en région parisienne une école qui
s'appelle lemon school à ozoir la
ferrière
eh bien elle est en tout point similaire
à une vieillesse
elle s'inspire des vieillesses elle l'a
simplement que deux ans d'existence donc
elle va grossir
puis a même aussi je trouve un réseau le
réseau s'appelle
la fédération des écoles de la
transition éducative et ce réseau en
fait il est aux écoles ce que les écoles
sont aux enfants c'est à dire un lieu un
espace dans lequel chaque école comme
pour les enfants va pouvoir développer
ses potentiels et ses talents va pouvoir
s'ouvrir aux autres va devenir en fait
une école apprenantes et ça on en a
rudement besoin aujourd'hui
alors on dit ça c'était les enfants au
canada on dit en afrique qu'il ya qu'il
faut tout un tout un village pour qu'un
enfant grandisse et bien imaginez
imaginer non pas un village mais une
communauté ou un écosystème un
écosystème dans lequel tous les enfants
n'est pas que les enfants d'ailleurs les
adultes aussi puissent aller explorer
les tannants savoir qu'ils sont font de
même développé ses talents et ses
potentiels devenir ce qu'ils sont à
l'intérieur
et puis plutôt que de reposer sur lire
écrire compter
obéir non plus qui était bon peut-être
pour le vingtième siècle
peut-être pourrait-on imaginer cet
écosystème dans lequel ce qui importe
c'est d'aimer de s'émerveiller de rester
curieux de découvrir voilà
[Applaudissements]